mm
tulle a réussi ton petit numéro toi mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait pour avoir un
fils paraît qu'il a réussi ta
provocation nominaux t'as vu ta tenue du
der garde et la glace et a vu ta tenues
costumes sur mesure cravate assortie
lunettes écaille made in england et
attaché-case à 23 ans quand je pense que
ta mère et moi on a le même blue jeans
depuis mai 68 était pas gêné il n'est
pas gêné leur entrée dans la chambre
dans cette tenue pendant que je suis en
train de fumer un petit joint avec mes
copains automnaux tu te sens pas déplacé
avec ton est de sortir du salon du
prêt-à-porter au milieu de mes copains
qui plane et ta chambre
sa chambre alors parlons-en sachant
explique moi c'est une chambre d'hôte
sse totu désinfecte ou quoi
j'avais tellement honte avant que mes
copains arrive que c'est moi qui inscrit
des slogans et des graffitis sur les
murs n'ont ni donc c'est à moi de faire
c'est à moi de faire parce que des
limites la provoc
quand je pense que devant mes copains tu
as été de vanter d'avoir fait son
service militaire devant gérard qui pour
se faire réformer avaler une fourchette
qui est encore coincé
et moi oui moi moi moi ton père qui me
suis fait un lavement avec une solution
javellisée 12 boîtes de maxi temps et
c'est à nous que tu viens parler de ton
adjudant à qui tu as envoyé thème on
veut en fait je comprends pas je
comprends pas tu connais quand même
notre passé à ta mère est à - tu connais
notre passé anarcho mao écolo autonome
et tu comprends pas notre monde ne te
voir cadre avec un plan épargne logement
assuré et pourtant et pourtant et
pourtant on a tout fait pour toi si si
si on a fait tous des parents pouvaient
faire pour leur enfant dans sa poussette
tu as assisté à toutes les grandes
manifs les gaz lacrymo on est et en
oxygène et plus tard et il vient en
lozère nourris au fromage de chèvre
tafer le larzac trompons pas de combat
je n'en avais tu valentin ou ta mère tu
vas d'entendre ta mère quand elle va
revenir de son voyage en inde avec sa
petite amie 30 ans quand elle va
apprendre que tu veux te marier parce
que monsieur veut se marier alors
explique moi ça existe encore cette
histoire le mariage mais sais tu que ta
mère et moi on a toujours vécu tous les
deux librement ensemble et avec celle
que tu as toujours appelé tati
tu vas entendre ta mère elle qui a été
membre du service d'ordre du hamelech
pendant dix ans quand elle va lire sur
la vitre arrière de la voiture
cette littérature pour dupont lajoie
avis à toutes filles qui rentrera dans
cette voiture le sourire aux lèvres
qu'elle ressortira la culotte à la main
bravo trois bombes non mais tu es qui se
disent non non mais tu veux que je te
dise je suis tellement écoeuré que moi
maintenant je démissionne alors il faut
plus rien me demander maintenant ses
rideaux terminé fini d'accord bien dit
bruno je lui ai demandé à pendant que
j'y pense t'as pas cent balles